what is it like for you truthfully
because you have put your heart and soul
into this for years and it really is
only in the last few days that you find
out if people like what you've done yeah
so it's like but what has it been like
because like I was at the screening last
night the packed audience laughing at so
many things me laughing at so many
things people clapping like so what the
hell is this all like for you it's so
real and it's I it's uh it's one of
those things that you hope is a reaction
uh I'm knowing that something that we
did with a lot of passion a lot of Pride
resonates with people from all walks of
life uh and if and the stuff that
doesn't it actually address curiosity to
learn more about it uh and being able to
have people feel like
finally I can see myself be a hero of
something is something truly special so
do you think true or false that the main
reason people enjoy the movie is that
you had fun with the Nintendo power
glove and that aspect of the Nintendo
Power Glove Powers everything
true
no but the Nostalgia of all those things
that we grew up being and using them
because I have I never had a Nintendo
glove like that I didn't either but I
had friends that did and every time I
wore it and I felt powerful because
you're like oh man and what if I can
create anything and I'm like we're here
in the movie and when we're building
this I'm like why not because it's like
it was written that there was something
like a shield I'm like how does that
Shield exist what are these deploy I'm
like
the Nintendo embrace the glove man I
have to do it what's funny is I was just
messing with it uh outside this room
they have it here yeah and I was about
to lift it and the guy's like oh you
need to put on white gloves I'm like
he's like this is a real prop I'm like
wait what yeah they actually you know
what I mean uh but people are gonna see
that and be anyway
um so one of the things about this film
is originally it was going to be going
straight to HBO Max and then they
decided to change it to being a
theatrical release and I am curious when
you got involved had that decision been
already made or were you involved in the
whole they changed it do you see what I
mean yeah of course no when I came into
the project the Mandate was at the time
that everything goes to HBO Max right
and um but once we started and I and I
was like you know sure I'll do the movie
of course every opportunity but I'm like
it can't be that the first time that we
have a Latino superhero uh front and
centered not just a Latino playing a
hero but where he's a Latino his family
is Latino and they're gonna be actually
being Heroes of their own stories for
the first time
I was like I cannot just live on
streaming like he has to go to the
theaters like the whole experience of
watching these Fantastical movies is to
be amazed I mean oh and what about being
able to see our culture represented
differently so we work very very hard to
create uh to do this world building
where
um the action sequences the suit the the
the the passion of the family and the
cultural aspects are presented in a way
worthy of watching it not only in the
theater but even on IMAX and being able
to see our communities that way
um I think that we did an amazing job in
bringing it to life on the concept uh
development of it all that at the end
you know uh one of her brothers decided
that this movie has to go to theaters
well one of the things is that like I
you're or with this movie no matter how
much money you get you're always against
the wall of the budget right so my thing
is like how the F would you pull this
movie off making it for 10 or 20 or 25
million and having it go to each you
know what I mean like it would be
impossible yeah yeah I don't I don't
honestly know the logic and the politics
behind it uh what I do know is that we
were able to be smart about how we
handle our budget that's why we went
um we went practical and that's why we
went to real locations and oddly enough
that also makes it feel bigger and more
immersed because even like this the
third act takes place in a real Fortress
that's 500 years old in Puerto Rico
that's not like a green screen set you
know so being able to do that and see
the magnificence of this building how
imposing it is and being able to capture
that and have fun with this adventure in
it it was a way for us to be able to
stretch our budget in a way that kind of
like delivers on it I guess well yeah
but also I think the audience and
including myself and I'm sure you when
you're seeing whole shots that are CGI
it just you're like it's like a cartoon
like when you have those practical
locations and you're adding CGI elements
it feels so much better you enhance it I
think one of the stuff that we agreed
upon is if we become so heavy dependent
on the VFX it will balloon uh like with
inflation and the expectations you have
to have so more stuff done prior to it
and and by doing it a lot in on real
locations or using a practical soon
uh our VFX supervisor
um Kelvin he was like it's better to
enhance him because I already have the
lighting reference everything is there
it's just enhancing or it's just doing
set extensions and by doing it that way
just felt like those are real that's
it's a real suit it's not a gray suit
and and and also might just Rubio
creating this suit with all recent Twin
Cities but at the same time creating a
suit which whose materials were done in
a way that it could be flexible so that
we can also do the stunts in real life
like it wasn't a video game or or mocap
it literally like starts a lot of cable
work all that stuff so that it feels
like it has weight so that it feels like
it's more
um
tangible listen and that's one of the
reasons people but one of the reasons I
bought into the movie but it um so your
movie is a little over two hours I asked
this of every director how did it change
in the editing room did you have like a
longer cut how did you end up with that
running time uh because they asked me to
do a movie less than two hours exactly
yeah 100 less than two hours and with
credits it bleeds into two seven uh my
version wasn't that much longer it was
like uh two hours and seven minutes oh
so just a little bit it was just a
little bit but it's you know stuff that
hurts but you have to compromise yeah I
I understand what's interesting is that
I've got an older I've learned the the
studio I I actually understand both
sides of it but also with Blu-rays you
can release things I hope so right I
hope we can because there's a lot of
really nice stuff that that
what was the last thing that you cut
before you picture locked like the thing
that really you know what I mean it was
that close to being in the movie there
was a really pretty scene
that I guess
um
that showed their family dynamic in
front of Jenny
you know like Jenny arrives and there's
the chaos and then they go out and say
you know but in between those moments
there was a beautiful Dynamic of of the
family and just Jenny witnessing and
absorbing it all and you can see on her
amazing performance how much she longed
for that experience
and and it was really it was a really
pretty pretty scene and
um and you can get this if the family
already had that chemistry
yeah the Barry was like a more festive
chemistry it was very nice I I missed
that scene yeah again hopefully Blu-ray
yeah you know
um so you get and I don't want to do any
spoilers but there is a uh there's a a
wide shot of the city and maybe I saw a
Lex Corp in the background and um so I
wanted to know do when you put a Lex
Corp sign in is that something that you
have to run up the flagpole to everybody
like how does that approval process work
and were there things you wanted to put
in in the background there that they're
like no yeah there's definitely things
that we wanted to put in that they were
like no because it might attach it to a
different
um
uh universe or something sure of course
we went we went hard with all the Easter
eggs that we could we wanted to have as
much as we could and when building the
city this uh Cosmopolitan City uh that
has all these neon lights and has all
these like um how you say like
holographic elements to it uh we wanted
to make it feel like it also belongs to
the greater DC Universe and Lex Corp is
Lex Corp in in about the same thing
Gotham law school like Gotham is Gotham
that will never disappear within the
lord of the superheroes so why not have
our hero also exist in a world that is
affected by all these other legacies
sure I even think I saw the Daily Planet
you know there's a few things in there
there's also
a box of Oreos in the bug layer
I don't know if you noticed that uh I'm
yes uh there's all this is a we'll
continue this once the movie is out to
get into some more stuff just a couple
things you know one of the things though
is this is your first time having this
kind of budget to play with VFX and this
kind of scale and scope so what did you
learn that you maybe wish you knew on
the first day because this is obviously
a growing period for you as a filmmaker
you know having these kinds of resources
that you've never had before I was very
lucky to have my heads up Department
have experience and
I trust them you know I think they're
they're masters of what they do and
having them navigate me having them
helped me navigate those Waters from
pre-production
allow that for me to not be so uh so
much of a clash of understanding I was
able to really focus on the things that
I care the most which is character and
emotionality and you don't need the
effects for that so as I was able to
trust them on this and the same way that
they trusted me and they made it very
easy for me to navigate that but if
there's something else that I now that I
know more that I could do later is
understanding where
uh where you want your energy to be
focused on uh right off the bat in order
for things to work out
easier because there's always going to
be challenges right there's always the
whole the whole job is about dealing
with obstacles
um but I think a lot of those obstacles
can be
addressed beforehand on pre-production
and avoided so that it can be a smoother
sailing it's always going to be bumpy
but it can always you can you can get
better tires if you know the tire the
road is going to be bumpy you know there
are some jokes in the movie that I was
very I mentioned this to you last night
that I was very surprised I'm not going
to spoil anything that I was very
surprised you were able to put in this
movie so I really want to know how did
you pull off some of the jokes that the
audience is going to see that are
surprising jokes in a superhero movie
this kind of film well
um
some of those jokes were actually taken
out of the comic itself
it might be just one frame of the comic
but there is jokes that we took from it
uh and there's also jokes that
um I guess the the
cultural differences
uh might benefit the existence of it
if that makes sense it's one of these
things where we can't I can't be
specific because everyone watching this
is not seeing the movie yet but I'm just
gonna say that you're gonna laugh a lot
yes you're gonna laugh a lot You're
gonna laugh a lot and a lot of it came
just authentic a lot of that stuff also
came on the day we we make it we made it
a habit that you know we go we shoot the
script
and once I feel that I get it I always
give them one less
run and we call it a fancy
and they said okay fancy and everybody
knows like this is the time that we can
be
obscene that we can be funny that we can
be whatever and a lot of those moments
came from the fancy takes
so I think like because if it doesn't
it's not force nobody's trying to pull a
joke uh it comes authentic to the
characters and the situation that makes
it relatable because they're free the
characters are free to do it themselves
within the boundaries of their
characters so it just helps to be to
have also talented people it just helps
this might be my last question I'm
almost out of time
um what did you actually want to include
from your own experiences and the
environments that you grew up in that
were really important to you to put in
this movie because this movie means an
awful lot to a lot of people yeah I mean
I wanted
um I wanted this this film because it is
the first time you see uh a a character
that is Latino on the paper then his
families are Latino
um I really wanted to
too grounded on the experiences that
form a lot of us right like oftentimes
in a lot of movies
um our stories are told like in the
middle of the sentence or in the middle
of the paragraph like boom gangster boom
you came out of prison like we never
have a chance to tell a history of where
we come from and the stuff that really
does affect us so how can we introduce
this character because this is what this
movie is it's like a First Act of a
potential Saga that we want to create
for the Blue Beetle journey and one of
the things that we wanted to do first of
all was hire Mexican actors not just
Mexican Americans but also go to Mexico
and get like the best stars from Mexico
for this movie like that
and they bring their own authentic
experiences to the movie and that helps
a lot to inform the conditions we want
to put their family in we want the Reyes
family to live in a world that is that
affects their environment that affects
their decisions like for example in my
case from Puerto Rico displacement
colonialism gentrification those are
things that are real threats home
insecurity not put it for the table
proper Health Care all those things that
are are villains but at the same time
what are all those things that are are
heroic things like Community like
standing up against a tyrant or standing
up against the things that weaken us but
doing it for the power of family and
community so by being able to hone in to
those uh experiences that I know
firsthand that the writer also knows
firsthand because got it is from
queretaro Mexico we were able to find
where uh our our different Journeys
intersect in a similarity of experiences
that not only affect our independent
individual countries but also affects
countries in Latin America and abroad on
that note uh I have to go They're Gonna
so I'm just gonna say man listen
congrats I'm really happy for you and I
appreciate you so much I hope it's a
huge hit I appreciate you so much man